بعد وصول
المباراه والرؤساء وكذلك قاده الوفود
الدول العربيه المشاركه في هذه القمه سيتم
التقاط الصوره التذكريه
قبل الدخول او انطلاق اعمال هذه القمه
العربيه التاليه والثلاثين التي تستضيفها
تفضل دكتور
النظر
للقسم الفراق اللي بتتواجد في الاعمال
الدراميه يعني مفيش حاجه زي كده هي القمه
او القمه اللي موجوده في العالم بتشوف ايه
الممكن وتعمله وتحقق فيه تراكم اذا كان في
قضيه جرى فيها خطوات الى الامام ويمكن
اضافه خطوات جديده على سبيل المثال
العلاقات العربيه الايرانيه كانت في ازمه
شديده
بعد الاتفاق السعودي الايراني حصل انفراج
في الازمه
هنا حمايه هذا الانفراج بيبقى مهم لانه في
حاجات زي ما يكون كده بتعمل وقف اطلاق
النار وبعدين ترجع تستانفه تاني
فهنا القضاء دي كلها اللي هي خاصه سد
النهضه دائما ما بتبقاش على تري واحده ما
تبقاش اعلى يعني صينيه واحده
بتفرض الازمات الاكثر حده نفسها لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقي والتقارير الاخباريه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات